book tv at cspan.org
coming up next michael mallis reports on
the life and continued influence of the
late north korean leader kim jong-il
he spoke with author and media
consultant cole striker at housing works
bookstore cafe in new york city for an
hour and 15 minutes
hey everybody thanks for coming
my name is cole um we have a couple of
great books here on sale uh dear reader
which is the book that we're celebrating
tonight is something that i finished
earlier this week and found completely
captivating and i hope
i'm glad to see you all here and i'm
sure that that'll be
illustrated in tonight's talk as well
the man of the hour our dear writer
michael malus is someone that i met at
the release party of this book that i
wrote hacking the future
we got to know each other because he
spent the entire night chatting at my
mother who was visiting new york
for the first time
and
from what i understand michael
being soviet-born
basically wanted to learn more about
what his parents went through
growing up under soviet rule and
decided to take a trip to north korea
and he bought every book of propaganda
he could find presumably all of these
written by
kim jong-il the former uh ruler of north
korea
and um
you know
collated that into a pretty interesting
book
and uh he pitched it around and nobody
understood it so he decided to put it on
himself
um and very successful kickstarter later
he self-published and um you know
now you have the finished product
michael has been ghost written i'm sorry
not ghost written i've made that mistake
before co-written
his name appears on the cover of the
book so that means he's a co-author
he's a co-author of several books
he is written alongside ufc champion
matt hughes he's written for a comedian
dl hughley
and
musician brett michaels who a lot of you
might know better as a reality tv star
um so he decided to turn his his
attention to
someone who could
realistically be called the most
mysterious man in the world um up until
his death a few years back
and um
i've i finished the book like i said
about a week ago and
it's kind of a comedy and it's also a
tragedy it starts off
with the phrase i remember the day that
i was born perfectly
no comma
which i think sets the tone pretty well
for the rest of the book um it's it's a
book that makes you constantly question
is this guy crazy
um is he that self-deluded that he
actually believes these things that he's
saying and that are being said about him
or is he that just that cold and
calculated and removed from humanity
that
um it doesn't faze him the fact that his
entire country is failing and starving
and dying
um
so it's it like i said it starts off
really funny though because there's all
these stories about how he's performing
these kind of miraculous things and
um you know
when when he's born the sun shines down
and parts a storm and
you know he climbed a tree at age three
and he
surprises all the adults around him with
his magnificent intelligence and
he almost
reminded me of like a tiny little chubby
eric cartman running around
encouraging his friends to criticize
themselves and
tattling and ingratiating himself with
the right people and
uh and then over time he gains more and
more power and being the son of kim
il-sung
the leader of the revolution
um of course uh eventually developed
ultimate power and it starts off kind of
rosy and he's making all these changes
and he's
you know leading groups and building
things and after a while it kind of
starts to fall apart and turns from a
comedy into a dark comedy and um
you know
you have this tremendous amount of
cognitive dissonance on display where
things aren't going the way that he
envisioned and it's not because it was a
bad idea in the first place it was
because they're not doing the bad idea
hard enough
and um
you know then the the dark comedy over
time turns to tragedy and you start to
see
um references to some pretty
troubling things like um the one that
sticks out in my mind are the little
sparrows which is the the korean word
that they use for um these little kids
that are orphaned and starving and
basically spend their lives
rooting around in garbage pits trying to
find anything edible bark or grass or
and of course none of this has anything
to do with
poor leadership or or the system of
government it's all because
there are these unseen
enemies of the revolution that are
preventing them from achieving greatness
so it's it's an amazing book and i
encourage everyone to pick up a copy we
only have
a handful but you can get it on amazon
and i encourage you to do so so
without further ado i'm going to welcome
our dear writer michael malus up to the
stage
[Applause]
okay
so i remember the day that i was born
perfectly this is something kim jong
presumably said no no no so okay said
about him all the funny lines come from
me
so
how i how i wrote this book you know i
read all the western books about north
korea and armfuls of north korean
propaganda and if you think communist
propaganda is boring you're wrong it's
10 000 times worse than boring
because boring you can kind of grit your
teeth and get through and these stories
are almost designed to kill the
consciousness of the reader and
eliminate critical thoughts so
i had to you know
make it humorous make it compelling make
it interesting so there are these little
bits of wit but he is not a very uh
witty figure at all uh everything is
said with complete utter sincerity uh
there's they're not fans of irony in
north korea whatsoever uh certainly not
with regard to the leaders who are
regarded as some sort of secular
religion right so how did you decide
when to insert your own
you know flourish
humorous flourish well the job of any
co-authors you know when i work with any
of my clients it's kind of like being a
defense attorney i'm helping the person
tell their story in the most clear
coherent way possible and the creative
narrative that you know any reader could
follow i like to call it like writing
novels about people who happen to be
real
so with this i very much tried to stick
to his own verbage as much as possible
again i tried to build a narrative
that's fun and interesting to follow and
and i've i've gotten very positive
response
because a lot of the stuff you know this
piece is here this piece is there it's
it's they're very much intent on
obfuscating the truth uh north korea
both internally and for external
purposes so there were no books out
there this is a huge hole in the market
i felt uh to start thinking like a
capitalist that if you want to sit down
and read about north korea and
understand their philosophy and
understand how they are that why why
they are the way they are there aren't
any books like they're out there there
there are some superb books out there
that are just very very dark very very
depressing with good reason uh so i
wanted to take a lighter kind of
perspective and at the same time you
know when you're getting the sugar
you're getting the medicine and
realizing this is the big humanitarian
crisis of our time
so speaking of
light-heartedness um
one of the most interesting things about
north korea to me is someone who writes
about the internet
is that
north korea has become this almost kind
of a joke to the west
and as i understand it this is something
that you
wanted to
attack
head-on um to demonstrate that
you know yes there are some things that
are
kind of humorous to us as outsiders but
also
this is a literal modern day holocaust
taking place
and so we have to temper any humor that
we find in this by
you know recognizing these these horrors
right like any good eastern european jew
i have a very dark sense of humor a very
gallows sense of humor and i think that
that is applied in america and the west
to north korea because i don't think
people understand just how bad it is
uh they understand you know that these
people have this wacky views about kim
jong-il and kim il-sung and they
understand that it's kind of regimented
society but they don't understand things
like everyone in the country every week
has to stand up in front of their peers
and be criticized and they have to
denounce their colleagues and if you
don't say anything that's really bad
and that everyone's you know every
minute of your day for your entire life
is kind of regimented and you're told
what to do uh and that you know you know
things like you don't have access to
food because of what your grandparents
were doing 50 years ago
little moments like this people don't
realize just how
uh dark and and
this regime really is so when they laugh
i i would hope they're laughing
from an informed place as opposed to
laughing at a sideshow
it's almost kind of
genius when you take a step back and
look at the mechanisms oh i thought
you're gonna talk about me i'm sorry
the the mechanisms by which
uh the regime
prevented any sort of dissent
you know you when you're punished it's
not just you being punished it's three
generations it's you know your family
gets sent to the enlightenment camp
um you know the
the self criticism sessions which were
which presumably were invented when kim
jong-il was in grade school is that well
that's the claim that kim jong-il
invented these criticism sessions when
he was in uh elementary school because
true comradeship lies in criticism if
you don't criticize your friends then
they're going to fall victim to
liberalism and spare time which is of
course the bane of the revolution uh i
think they borrowed it from the chinese
actually but they they've stuck to it
where the chinese have not we throw
around the term orwellian a lot but as
i'm as i read through this book
you see these
these methods of
uh stifling any sort of thought that is
not sanctioned by the regime
that i feel like
straight out of 1984. it's completely
unprecedented and it is straight out of
1984 there's you know that famous
anecdote in 1984 where the protagonist
has to go through the newspapers and
edit out any past references that
contradict the current narrative we were
always at war with eurasia right and i
found the same thing in the north korean
propaganda because i got books that were
published in the 60s 70s 80s 90s and
through today like all the great hits
and you'll find in an early story it'll
say
kim il-sung went to india to meet with
the prime minister and the same story
will be told in a later book and it'll
say
kim il-sung went to a foreign country to
meet with the head of state
so the facts just fall away and you can
see them consciously trying to put north
korea into a fog
i spoken to refugees about what it's
like there and they don't teach them
geography
they are you know it's it's how
ubiquitous in american western schools
is the world atlas and you know learning
about europe and africa and south
america and all of that they are taught
about china japan the u.s uh and
you know south korea and russia and
that's pretty much it so
you it's absolutely pervasive their
thought their attempts to control the
minds of the populace
yeah
um
you mentioned earlier something along
the lines of that this is like a
secularized divine right of kings
scenario where
everything that the regime claims
becomes gospel and reality almost bends
toward
those claims like it's not what you're
seeing there's a story in the book about
um
the
i'm sorry if i pronounce it incorrectly
but the mountain that
well uh this is the mountain that is
just the the greatest pride of any north
korean
and um any korean
right because they don't consider it to
be north korea right and it's the
ancestral home of all the korean people
right
and there's a story where
kim jong-il asks this question of his
advisors
about
what's the highest mountain in the world
and someone says
mount everest and
he says no you're wrong it's actually
mount pick two and the reason why is
because
height
shouldn't be
measured by actual height but rather
like the spiritual greatness of yeah
because now pick 2 is the birthplace of
the revolution therefore it's the
highest mount in the world and it is
absurd but you have to imagine what it's
like growing up in a country where this
is what you're taught as your reality
and even if like i met a refugee and
there's a very another story in in deer
reader uh which i talk about which they
repeat at nauseum this brilliant moment
where kim jong il's in kindergarten and
his teachers teaching him one plus one
is two and he goes no that's not correct
and she's like what do you mean little
kim jong-il and he goes well if i have a
drop of water and i add it to another
drop of water i have a big drop of water
not two drops you know therefore one
plus one sometimes equals one and if all
the korean people put their minds
together it'll be the greatest force in
history and the teacher goes
yeah she's amazed she's like what a
genius you know
in between tears
and i met a refugee and i asked her
about this and
she in first grade was hearing the story
and she goes to herself this is the most
ridiculous thing i ever heard right but
she had the presence of mind to keep her
mouth shut because if you start
challenging these things they are coming
for your family this is going to get
back to your mom and your dad so you
very very early on have to have your
blinders on head down mouth shut
and a lack of freedom you know what that
means is you're just kind of in this
bunker mindset where you just don't
notice anything and you know we have a
lot of these videos on youtube where um
people go there and and the good guides
you know everyone when you visit north
korea as a guide the guides tell them
these absurd uh things they ask them
like there's this very vice video you
know they go to this banquet hall no
one's there and he asks the waitresses
he goes where is everyone the waitress
says oh they all just left
and it's like you know how crazy they
are but the fact is for them to say we
don't have any customers is criticism of
the restaurant and the regime
so you have to pretend everything's
great you know just like any hostage if
you ask a hostage you know if you got a
hostage of videotape you don't ask the
hostage why do you have bruises on your
face
they are not in a position to say
because the guy who kidnapped me is
beating me so that's where a lot of
these you know absurd claims are coming
from they have guns to their head these
people yeah there's these stories
throughout the book where
kim jong-il will make some claim
and about a field that he would never
have a possibility of having expertise
in like engineering or music or oh yes
there's a there's a scene where he
creates a new form of opera that's true
right yeah
and uh the the head of opera or whatever
says
you know kim jong-il suggests like why
don't we do it this way and then the
head of opera kind of scratches his chin
and goes
you know it's i've never thought about
that it just might work
a lot of these stories only work if you
are under the presumption that everyone
in north korea is learning disabled
because here's how they work it's not
like kim jong-il goes to a school and
teaches the kids he will meet with the
best experts in north korea in that
field and he will say a completely
obvious idea and they'll all exclaim we
never thought of this and it's like
these are people working in this field
ostensibly for decades like a good
example is they built something called
the tower of the jewish idea which is
the tallest obelisk in the world which
uh even though it looks exactly like the
washington monument is actually inspired
by korean architecture supposedly right
and the story they tell is all these
architects are brainstorming how to make
this building
and they go we want to make it the
second tallest
obelisk in the world and kim jong-il
goes we should make it the tallest and
they're like oh my we never even
consider that
and it's just like really like yes and
but this is what's presented with a
straight face to make him that great
everyone else has to be knocked down a
peg and in fact that has pernicious
consequences because
the the regime and kim jong-un currently
can claim with a straight face that the
leader is working hard as much as he can
but it's the ruling regime that are not
putting his brilliant ideas into
practice and that's why you're hungry
and in fact they will say that the
reason kim jong-il has those sunglasses
is because his eyes are bloodshot from
staying up all night working for the
people
now
let's talk about the average north
korean and
i think that a lot of people
when kim jong-il died
watched these videos and they see just
the crying and the relentless
you know
women just absolutely overcome with
grief that this guy died
what are we really seeing in these
videos right so kim jong-il actually you
know kind of addressed how the people
felt about him his father uh was in
charge of north korea for something like
close to 50 years uh and all the
refugees still venerate and love kim
il-sung the great leader uh he's like
and kim jong-il to the great leaders
like nancy sinatra to frank sinatra no
one regards the second one as anything
other than a function the first and the
first one is head and shoulders you know
above the other one so
you know when he was when he took over
in 94 when kim jong-il took over his
father the people you know had to follow
suit and
pretend they revered him as much as they
revered his dad it was a completely
uh unanimous vote by the way there's a
unanimous vote well yeah of course uh he
has to support the people um but
and his campaign slogan was do not
expect any change for me that literally
was what all the billboards said when he
took over um but there's a secret tape
recording of him and he said
all this cheering is fake they're not
cheering from the bottom of their hearts
so he knew damn well that these people
were not sincerely you know affection
toward him
the the morning when his father died was
very very sincere if you have anyone
running your country 50 years you're
going to be terrified if only what's
going to happen now but when kim jong-il
died they were that was fine but again
being a surveillance society where all
your neighbors are reporting on
everything you do every week you damn
well better make a show of how sad you
are uh you know when the the deer leader
dies
yeah so
when you've talked to these refugees um
is there some some level of
deprogramming that has to happen or are
they immediately
as soon as they hit the shores of some
other country thank god i'm out of here
that was insane
uh you know everything about that
experience was was brutality and and
horror one of the worst things about
north korea is people think that if the
regime vanished everything's going to be
fine it's not going to be fine for
decades these people have never seen a
computer they have no idea of history
uh you know there's some funny anecdotes
you know of like refugees in seoul
going up to an atm and wondering how a
person fits in there you know things
like this but this is we have a nation
of 24 million people um because they
don't understand how computers work and
they just assume that there's a little
right there's got to be a guy you know
uh and they're treated with with
great contempt in the south they have to
work on their accents which our guard is
very low class and and uh and you know
treat with contempt um so it's a very
kind of uh uh there's no kind of happy
ending um to north korea do the south
koreans want reunification do they want
the regime to collapse
certainly no one wants the regime to
collapse but they reunification is less
and less a priority for the south and
that is another kind of a lot we're even
seeing some people from the north
repatriate to the north after escaping
because in the south they are not able
to hold down jobs they're used to all
their lives being told what to do so
they show up late to work you know they
have chips on their shoulder because
they're treated second class citizens so
it's really uh
it's it i mean this regime has been you
know a vampire on these people for 70
years and you know when the vampire's
dead you're still not going to be a
healthy individual so it's even darker
than that but again the book's very
funny
it is it's true
um kim jong-il's not a huge fan of the
us
oh no no so kim jong one of the other
orwellian things that they do is you
can't refer to americans or japanese
it's always japanese devils or us
imperialists so even the language is
used as a technique to turn people
against the enemies of um
of the regime and in fact there's this
video i watched there was a canadian
reporter he went to north korea and he
was walking down the street with his
guides and he got punched in the face by
this elderly north korean man
with good reason because a the elderly
north green man probably assumed he was
american but the americans were the
fault were blamed for the famine so we
can't have food because the americans
have an embargo so this man in his mind
you know caused the starvation of his
family
can you talk a little bit about uh the
book is partitioned by
these various interactions with the u.s
over the years and each interaction with
the u.s goes something like this
it goes a little something like this in
the u.s
you know decides that they want to
encroach in some way or
monitor something you know nuclear
activity
whatever it is
and the north koreans
have to capitulate because they have
zero
power and this is somehow spun
through
this double speak that
into a north korean victory oh yeah so
could you give an example of that like
there's several in the book that i'm
thinking of well it's really kind of
great because
they
constantly are uh
you know
any regime you have to have the other
like if we let down our guard they are
going to come in here and invade like
what is true is in 1861 the us general
sherman went to korea the first you know
western country to visit korea and what
is also true is the koreans killed
everyone on board and burned the ship
down so korea was known as the hermit
kingdom long before it was north korea
it was very very very xenophobic south
korea remains you know largely
xenophobic so one of you know you have
and their idea is the americans are
biding their time because every so often
you know they want to come in and they
want to take us out and one of the great
things i learned while writing this book
is all the criticism of north korea is
addressed at some point in their
literature they don't sweep it on the
rug so they you know
go after all these you know criticisms
of them and they have answers for all of
them you know they say why are we going
to have reunification like how can you
believe all these things and the re they
from their perspective which is not
completely crazy they went nuclear
because president george bush went on tv
and had basically a kill list of iraq
iran and north korea and they're like
look if you go after the countries that
don't have nukes like iraq and the
countries that do have nukes like you
like you know like iran is increasingly
happening you negotiate with them so of
course you're going to give us an
opportunity you know to acquire nuclear
weapons and this is a great triumph for
us has your opinion of american for
foreign policy changed at all since you
started researching this
uh
um i am not a particular fan of american
foreign policy that said i don't think
that there's any good answers
with american foreign policy vis-a-vis
north korea a huge percentage of the
countries underground they 100 percent
have nuclear weapons they 100 would use
them if they needed to if they felt they
needed to um so
there's no but again a lot of times you
know
america will do things that are horrible
and then after the fact we'll be called
to task and it's no one from any country
likes to be invaded and have children
killed by drones in the name of
democracy so it's it's there's some i
think americans and i hate criticizing
americans being an immigrant but i think
people often don't realize how things
look from the other perspective and
somehow it's not unpatriotic to be like
you know if i were an iraqi and i had
killer robots from the sky killing my
kid i might not you know be waving the
stars and stripes
so if you were
obama
oh god okay
yeah um and
let's say tensions escalate and
kim jong-un says
you know we're going to continue to
you know brutalize our our citizens
they're gonna they boast about what they
do yeah right but let me just say one
more thing in in their double speak they
will say human rights you know because
they're criticized for human rights
abuses right and they say with a
straight face human rights in our
definition means national sovereignty so
when you criticize us and what we do to
our people you are violating korean
human rights and isn't it also about
how
they perceive
the people that they abuse to not be
human so any anybody that is thrown into
a prison is by definition a class
class enemy and as kimmel sung the
founder said class enemies have to be
exterminated that's the word he used
exterminated to three generations so
according to the juche idea the
philosophy of north korea and to me talk
a little bit about the jew sure
according to the jewish idea and just
you know most hardcore communist
philosophy you only have a right to life
as a as a member of society it's the
side that grants you this right and once
you betray your society you're an
unperson and you can be vanished and
destroyed now the jewish idea they very
much tried to
make uh
you know korea unique in every single
way so the judicial idea is their ruling
philosophy and it's an animal game of
you know mysticism communism fascism and
and kind of imperialism and basically
what juche translates to is that which
kimmel song likes it's often you know
described as self-reliance but it's also
you you have juche gymnastics and juchi
acrobatics and and you change it it can
basically change according to the whims
of right right and the definition of
juche changes and and you know we we
talked about him inventing the opera
reinventing the opera it's like
you should know what juche upper is all
the definition jupiter
opera is that which i like it's it's
like of course these people who are in
the arts are crippled and when you're
especially you know in communist regimes
when you work in the arts and you which
is a very nuanced area when you
introduce nuance into works that's very
very that's typo you have to walk kim
jong-il in this book which one of my
favorite anecdotes he really goes after
the mona lisa he hates the mona lisa
it's no longer regarded as a masterpiece
and i asked my mom who grew up under
style and i said why does kim jong-il
hate the mona lisa and she pauses and
she goes because it's ambiguous and
that's exactly right art has to have a
very clear message if it's not
propaganda it's not art um so they the
the pervasiveness of the and the of the
juchi idea and what they described as
the monolithic ideological system they
boast that everyone in this country
thinks the same
and
to them it's a source of pride and to us
you know knowing what that really means
it's just the source of the most
unimaginable horror
i was
you know reading this book personally i
i was struck by the similarities between
this policy this attitude towards art
and the attitude towards art that i grew
up with in rural pennsylvania surrounded
by
what
many people might consider to be
fundamentalist christians
this idea that we have to create our own
music because any music that isn't kind
of furthering the cause is invalid right
and any any art that's ambiguous and
doesn't have a specific
you know reference to
the redemptive story of christ is
invalid
and i guess i just wanted to ask you
about like did you also notice those
parallels um about for instance it might
not be on the right it might be left
wing this uh
tendency to
demonize um opposing ideas to the point
where they're censored well yeah they're
not going to demonize opposing ideas
because they won't be introducing them
to the populace so you're just taught
the one idea and this one you have to
believe this you have to mirror it's
funny you said that because uh i have a
good friend who lives in the midwest
he's a you know born-again christian and
he said his favorite genre of music is
christian you know christian music and
it's like i don't like music that i
agree with and that's like saying what
kind of music do you like love songs
that never made sense to me uh but but
again yeah all he says explicitly art
has to have a message and
they're not left-wing
this is one of the big misconceptions
about north korea they are very they
have all the check marks of traditional
fascism except for like having business
involvement with the economy they are
they're the most homogenous country on
earth they are the most xenophobic
country on earth they are violently you
know and anything foreign and they're
against they're the fourth largest
military which is amazing given a
country of 24 million
they are very militaristic very much for
strength very much for you know kind of
crushing the weak uh they have contempt
for christianity because they will in
their they will say that the christian
message of turning to their cheek is a
trick to get people to let their guard
down and to bring down shame to a nation
and in fact there's a very famous story
in north korea that these missionaries
come and they brand the children with
crosses and acid on their face you know
because they're just these and they
inject them with diseases so you know
the missionaries are really this kind of
like sinister forces homosexuals too
well they don't talk about that uh
there's that one story that that um
uh where the america in 1968 the
american ship puebla was captured by
north korea and according to the north
koreans the americans were complaining
not because of their poor treatment
because as homosexuals that's how they
express themselves they want to have sex
with each other because that's how they
express their individuality and kim
jong-il says this will not be happening
on our pure soil
so again speaking of fascism it's a very
very chaste puritanical uh country um
and they have a caste system you know
based on they did something
they're orwellianism everything that's
so evil has such a great name they had
something called the understanding
people project sounds great right i love
understanding people who's against
understanding people right it sounds
like some saturday morning you know show
about hey let's understand people what
do they do they interviewed every single
person in north korea
and they collated what you and your
family were doing up to like your second
cousin and based on that you were
granted a rating that determined how
loyal you were to the regime uh it's
like and it's got like 53 steps you're
not told what your credit rating is but
it determines who you marry where you go
to school even where you live and you
can't travel within the country you have
to live where you're assigned and the
people with the bad uh
sung bun which is what the term is
called uh were all forced to live in the
northeast they refused to refer to it as
a caste system it's not a caste system
because that goes against communism
they're like trans political like they
present as communists but they're really
really really not and in fact in 1980
when kim jong-il was um presented to the
world as the official successor to kim
il-sung the the second world the common
iron curtain countries were like this is
absolutely insane this goes against
everything we stand for and kim
il-sung's like sorry about it like what
are you gonna do
so he
and to this day the north koreans get
off on defiance
and giving the finger to these other
nations like people ask what should we
do and the answer usually is pressure
china they revel in telling china we're
not going to do what you say you're
chinese we're korean your your answers
won't apply to us shut up you know and
bring it what and it's really when you
have people who are digged in to that
extent how the hell are you going to get
them out
so let's talk
about kim jong-il
and this he's sort of the lens at which
you look through at the entire country
and uh i'm just gonna say one thing one
thing that worked out perfectly is he
was born during world war ii when korea
was separated into two countries he died
94. so it worked out that his life story
works out to a history of the korean of
north korea as a nation and since he's
there for his gump wherever anything
happens he's there you know involved his
life by telling his life story in dear
reader he tells the story of north korea
so his father kim al-sung
was he
sort of this um you know lenin to i'm
really going to make some
wrong metaphors here i'm sure but was he
kind of more like the true believing
good guy to kim kim jong-il's like boy
king
uh bad guy that took over well what
happened was you know the soviet union
was given north korea to kind of run
after world war ii and they needed to
install like a puppet and they didn't
have that many options um because you
know communism did not have a strong
hold in in the north of korea at the
time so they settled on kim il-sung who
was this kind of ragtag revolutionary in
fact rumor has it they had to teach him
how to speak korean again because he's
always speaking russian uh growing up
and they thought he'd be a malleable
kind of figure like most these other you
know puppet dictators but he was not you
know he he very much had ideas of his
own he had these hardcore korean
national ideas nationalist ideas so uh
and
you know
after the korean war stalin died and
khrushchev took over khrushchev very
much liberalized the soviet union and
this did not sit well with kim il-sung
at all in fact that's why khrushchev on
kim jong-il's official enemies list they
despise him they despise this idea of
closing down gulags you know and
allowing internal migration and kind of
external news and the point they make to
defend kim jong-il taking over is look
what happened with stalin you let in
some jerk after and you bring down the
revolution i've got my father's blood i
will see things through and
make the revolution conclude through
generations to the end and in fact one
of the things they have they have
something called they have ten
commandments there's ten commandments
that run north korea it's not the
constitution which is the western
artifice for you know for appearances
purposes and number ten is the korean
revolution will be followed through
through the generations so you know this
dynastic succession is in there and it
speaks to their fascist obsession with
pure blood since this family has the
blood of mount pick 2 you know in their
g in their veins they are the only ones
who can really bring koreanis to the
world but there's this weird paranoia
every time that succession is brought up
where it's like oh we're not it's not a
dynasty it's not you know these people
were voted in and
but clearly they weren't i mean why even
pay lip service to to this idea that
there was some sort of
fair uh election or well it's it it's
not a fair election no doubt but it's a
fair uh choice from their perspective
because the best man got the job and
just ask him i mean is there anyone
better in north korea at architecture
you saw those guys they wanted to make
the second tallest stone tower i mean
they will tell you with a straight face
that kimmel's son can literally walk on
water that he can teleport uh i asked
the refugee i'm like was this a metaphor
was he like fast moving with this troop
she's like no no he could teleport and
she believed that if he signed his name
like his the signature can lift off the
page and fly through the air so uh you
know it's very much follows the
christian idea that you know
why was it christ that was following god
it's just like well who else is it to be
it's not going to be you know john the
baptist you know he's not divine born
kim il-sung the father
is invoked throughout the book
long after his death as being
this kind of
you know person that we all owe a great
debt to
um
and kim kim jong-il is obviously doing
everything for his memory and to
continue his legacy and his vision and
he's still the president he's the
president even in debt so what is what
is the kind of purpose of kim il-sung as
an idea right now in north korea uh i
think kim il-sung has the same purpose
in north korea in a twisted way that the
founding fathers do here
so it's this you know i have him make
the joke that you all in america make
fun of kim il-sung being so amazing but
you all believe that the greatest minds
in history were all localized in the
17th century and 13 wrenching colonies
you know on the atlantic ocean so the
idea is that he
saved korea a tiny country they boast
about this they call themselves a shrimp
among whales
he defeated the the [ __ ] devils during
world war ii single-handedly he defeated
the us imperialist during the korean
liberation war and he was the one who
kept all these enemies at bay for
decades uh and the you know the enemies
are just waiting at any moment and and
if but for him you know korea would be
part of china or part of japan or
something like that and look at south
korea they'll point out where you know
the women are being given aids by the
aids-ridden soldiers we send over there
so we can use the koreans as guinea pigs
um
one question that i had in my mind the
entire time i was reading this book is
is kim jong-il a madman
you know is he so far down deep into
this delusion that he is
essentially the messiah
um
or is he just this cold calculating
you know
villain of history well we know he's not
a madman because mad men don't tend to
be able to execute their ideas very well
for that long so if you look at the
history all these other nations fell
away
including the mothership the soviet
union and north korea is still plugging
along you know if you are willing to let
10 percent of your population starve
uh rather than lose your grip on power i
don't know that that's crazy as much as
it is pure evil i mean he did this
consciously and with intentionality he
refused to let the un see how bad things
were doing he refused to let people have
food via you know uh you know other
programs for foreign programs because he
said if people are getting food from
abroad they won't need the government
anymore and then we'll be you know out
of luck so he was very very conniving
and in fact he only got his leadership
position because he was so conniving it
was not at all a given that he would
take over but he worked the system kind
of game of thrones style uh and he held
on you know white knuckling until the
very end where everyone was predicting
uh in the west and even in the east that
he was not going to last long after
kimmel's song kimmel song you know was
this charismatic man of the people kim
jong-il only ever spoke one sentence in
public was a recluse so you know he in
every sense the son was the inferior of
the father i guess like aryanism and
you know he did what he needed to do and
he stayed through the end
yeah
um so what does this say about
the the
method of north korean
uh perpetuating this regime uh you know
what
why did it work
you know it's it obviously didn't work
in terms of feeding the people and
there's no prosperity there's nothing
you know there's no interesting
inventions coming out of north korea
there's no progress but
it worked in the sense that the
regime has maintained power why well
where all other hyper-communist regimes
have failed north korea has somehow hung
on this long well i think uh there's
certain things that first of all the
ruthlessness is really going to help if
you
are going to
when
when when in north korea when something
bad happens to you
they will take three generations of your
family you don't have a trial uh they
show up in the middle of the night they
take your family you get sent to the
camps and you don't know who it was in
your family
that uh got who disobeyed the regime and
got you sent there you're not told what
your crime is or how long your your
estate stay is in these awful places so
that's number one uh
it's a good way to maintain obedience by
having everyone in the nation be hostage
the fact that they've kind of
crowdsourced surveillance
and had every single person be a spy and
everyone else is going to be extremely
useful
and the fact that they you know i have
him in the book boast about censorship
in the same way as look we have the
juchi idea all these other ideas are now
known to be false and outdated you don't
have rotten food in your cupboard right
so this isn't censorship it's progress
so the fact that these people have no
exposure to outside ideas which the
communist countries always did uh one of
the famous anecdotes and and my mother
can attest to this
is that it was shows like dynasty in
dallas that brought down the soviet
union because the women are watching how
the poor people on these shows are
living and they don't have toilet paper
and they're like what is this nonsense i
don't want this but they don't have that
option in north korea the only movies
they're allowed to see and that's only
if you're at the very high levels are
like titanic which is clearly a disaster
of capitalism and like dickens and and
books like jenny gerhart which is just
this depressing naturalism so they are
very much
unlike any other nation in the world
kept in a state of complete isolation
which is increasingly falling apart
because when you can't feed your police
force
the border between north korea and china
has gotten very very porous because
they're hungry so the people go to china
they trade things they come back with
food they pay off the border guard and
when you don't have electricity in your
entire town and
and dogs in china you know have these
little lights you're realizing what
we're being told isn't true and it's
very it's a very gossipy culture this is
what happens we have a surveillance
state everyone talks and people are
increasingly realizing this is all
nonsense
because it's like dominoes the lie is so
big and so pervasive it's like as soon
as one piece falls away you're like wait
a minute none this makes sense it
doesn't add up like one and one equaling
one
so in ever and every other regime
that has approached this level of
pervasiveness
of the surveillance and the oppression
nothing's come close in my view but go
ahead well
the ones that have come the closest
anyway
you have
these kind of concessions to capitalism
where
people start
developing black markets and they're
trading underground is there anything
like that happening
i mean you just sort of alluded yeah
that's what's been happening now and
this is actually kind of interesting for
gender issues is they have these markets
because the government gave up at the
late 90s and being able to feed the
people through the public distribution
system so they're like you know what
juche means self-reliance so you rely on
yourself get fed see you later um so
increasingly you have these markets and
kim jong-il knew about them he allowed
them every so often he'd have them shut
down uh kind of like fumigating so that
people know who's really in charge but
it was a mecca a recognized mechanism of
getting the people fed and they've tried
these little experiments uh like there's
the race on economic zone which is a
kind of a partnership with south korea
which is very very guarded and very kind
of isolated localized even with the
north korea but their perspective on
economics is so
uh genuinely crazy and and there's this
anecdote um towards the end of his life
kim jong-il gave everyone in the country
it's either a 1 000 or a 10 000 raise i
don't remember it was literally one of
that everyone in the country now makes
ten times as much money and within a
month inflation hit ten thousand percent
and he genuinely felt this was a
subterfuge and people undermining his
plan
and he had the finance minister shot uh
because he didn't understand why this
was happening so
it's funny in a sense but when you
realize what these funny ideas happen it
means you know massacres and and just
vast vast death
so
we talk but basically this this is
slowly falling apart is kind of the
takeaway
and that it can't last forever
do you have a prediction
uh there's that famous line i think from
steinbeck where he was asked how did you
go broke and he goes two ways gradually
and then suddenly
i think it already has fallen apart in
the 90s when the famine hit what they
refer to as the arduous march kim
jong-il invented his philosophy which he
called sun goon which means military
first which basically meant the military
eats first
and under this it was no longer the
party the workers party that runs north
korea it's the it's the army and this is
basically martial law uh so this was a
big big change uh and this was them you
know getting even more you know kind of
violent and and you know digging their
heels in further so there is change but
it's just in change in the in some
senses it's better but the other senses
they're just doubling down in the
brutality
and how do you think this is going to
play out that eventually the rest of the
world is going to say hey you got to
stop this or we're going to invade
or that the people are going to decide
that they've had enough or
uh i was talking to a friend of mine who
works with these issues and he had a
very good point which is it's a great
thing that kim jong-un killed his uncle
because now all those people at the
party elites at the very top realize
their days could be numbered if he's
going after his own family i i might not
be safe so that might be a possible
opportunity
that said if it hasn't happened for 70
years i first of all invading i think is
almost it will almost definitely not
happen uh for many many many reasons but
i i think china wouldn't let it uh why
well because if north korea regime goes
down you've got 24 million refugees
pouring into china who don't speak
chinese who have no skills uh who are
hungry and it's just going to be a
complete nightmare uh south korea
certainly the the border between north
and south korea is the most militarized
border in the world called the dmz
ironically clinton said it kept him up
at night and there's all these land
mines you know for for miles and miles
and miles so they have to go to china um
so
invading would be
a complete horror and what's the worst
part is all the people in the
concentration camps and you can see them
on google earth
uh and and you know it's just really
really you know just awful this is
happening right now obviously
they're all told if we get invaded we're
going to kill all of you and we're
burning these camps down just like the
nazis you know kind of tried to do it in
world war ii so again
you know if you're going to invade this
country you do so knowing that
immediately hundreds of thousands of
prisoners are going to be murdered
so what's
what do we do but it's a very funny book
what's the solution as an as any outside
government
like if you were advising any of these
people the only
solution i had
being a dear writer is write a book
let people understand what's going on
they're not crazy there's a complete
logic to everything they do their
actions are predictable and coherent and
hopefully someone will read this book
and it'll get the wheels turning in the
right direction because i do not have
any answers like how do you save a
people who have been so
you know lost and oppressed for so long
i mean
another metaphor i always use is the
slaves after the american civil war were
for decades you know it was you know
horrible for them and
not to be comparing tragedies but in
north korea it's it's it's amazing i
mean at least in the south they were in
a semi-free state this is just a
complete uh
nightmare system
so we we see
increasingly um
these media companies going into north
korea and producing documentary content
why does north korea let these
people into the country i mean well
north korea very much plays into western
views on them you know a lot of times
i'll read a book and they'll mention it
like a western book and they'll mention
some kind of crazy north korean news
article i look in the footnotes and look
for the original source only to find
it's been scrubbed meaning they read
that western book and like okay this is
too crazy that that all these birds were
dying because the kimono song died and
things like that so they play up their
exoticness and their wackiness because
then you you know you're nervous that
this guy has his finger on the trigger
you know kind of dr strangelove thing
and you don't want to engage with them
because when someone's crazy you don't
know what they're going to do next so
they very much uh kind of are aware of
how they're perceived and then they feed
into it
and they have an instagram account they
do have an instagram they're following
you they don't they didn't follow them
but they liked the book cover they liked
it yes and in fact when my friend went
to north korea uh they liked her picture
and she got so scared she liked all of
theirs
um but why why they are letting in all
these media companies is
uh they are desperate for money
uh they're the first communist nation to
default in their loans so they had no
hard currency and they produced nothing
of value so they need money so they
could buy gasoline they have very little
electricity um so that's one of the few
things that they can sell is tourism
and these are all very tightly
controlled tours of course and from
their perspective the rest the world
wants to know in north korea how great
they are and and this is their way of
sharing with the rest of the that's the
can see that they have to play into that
everyone's interested in them because
they're so awesome and let's let them
see how awesome we really are tell us
about your relationship with your guide
sure so uh
one of the most
when i work with a celebrity when i
co-author a book of theirs my job
basically is to kind of crack them and
get in their head because they're going
to give me the press release answers and
i want them to tell their truth and
their real story and there's a lot of
techniques i use for this and it's the
whole process but whatever so when i was
in north korea i really wanted to get
inside my guide's head because i really
want to know what she thought how she
felt how she viewed her
uh her country and she reminded me a lot
of my mom you know she was you know
young and my mom you know would have
been that age when she left the soviet
union even the soviet union was
obviously far better than north korea so
it was it was
very touching because first of all
they're very funny
people can't get their head around that
they're very funny when i was leaving
north korea asked my guide i said if i
can send you anything from the west what
do you want me to send you and
immediately she goes a porsche
[Music]
and they have a famous symbol chalema
which is a pegasus they have there it's
their symbol of speed and i go i'm not
sending you a porsche and don't ask me
to send you cholima either and she goes
we've got the original one here why do i
need you to send it to me
so really quick and she said i want
hand lotion
there's none in the whole country she
just wants soft hands and she goes i
want perfume and i and the person with
me goes what kind of perfume do you want
and she's struggling for the words
because if you've never owned perfume or
don't know anyone who's ever owned
perfume how are you going to have the
language for that she goes i just want
to smell
like a girl she's like i just want to
smell feminine
and this is i think you know
listen if the worst you could say about
countries there's no perfume they've got
it pretty good but i think this is just
speaks to how pernicious and pervasive
the control is if we don't make it uh
you don't need to have it you don't you
don't get to have anything nice or
pleasurable or little treats or anything
like that once a year on the leaders
birthdays they'll give all the kids in
the country candy and notebooks you know
and it's supposed to be this great thing
but
i think it's better when the kids can
have candy as a treat you know whenever
they want uh not and not in celebration
of this man who's taken everything from
you and your family and that lack of
perfume is not just a matter of
them not having perfume but it's also
that
that that you know using perfume would
be some sort of
uh attack on this idea of sameness oh
yes
you're you have this kind of tall poppy
syndrome you're standing out from the
crowd what you think you're better than
there but it you know it's very much you
know frowned upon and it's interesting
because in pyongyang it's the highest
cat to live and even step foot in
pyongyang you have to have the highest
level of political reliability and then
these refugees are like oh what's it
like you know because they hear they
hear stories about pyongyang it's this
miracle like the capital from hunger
games
and in fact one of my refugee friends
loves the hunger games and she said it
was like north korea she's like how did
they know and i'm like am i supposed to
laugh
um
it was
um
but
so so it but in pyongyang they they
watch south korean like tv shows and
they use south korean slang
uh she taught me the term ipo which
means cute and when i tell the refugee
i'm like you know ippo you're cute and
the referee goes oh you learned that in
seoul i go no no i learned that in
pyongyang she goes that's south korean
so they regard themselves very much as
cosmopolitan worldly you know they
they're more like new york than they are
like uh you know these little boondock
towns they've never left the but they've
never left the country and they never
and it would another really kind of
poignant sad moment my friend had gone
earlier you know he's the one who showed
me that it's legal to go anyone can go
you know i would encourage anyone to go
because just amazing
and his guide at the end was like oh i
hope you come back and visit us i had a
great time talking to you because to
them it's like talking the only time dr
foreigner and he goes you know oh i
would love it if you come visit me in
los angeles you know he plays dumb and
she kind of turns around and cries like
literally and she's like i'm afraid that
won't be possible so
these people uh
know that they are trapped
um so again it's books hilarious
so what's the deal with this kim jong-un
what's the deal with kim jong-un am i
right
is he another kim jong-il is he uh
is he even more of this like playboy who
doesn't care about anything other than
you know eating expensive sushi and
kim jong-un was plan c you see joffrey
from game of thrones is what i mean i've
been told i look like joffrey uh and i
don't know that that's true but i think
that's a that's apparently that's a bad
person to aspire to so
again it's not ag this kim jungle makes
this point and it's true it's not
strictly a hereditary monarchy because
their eldest son was passed over the
eldest son kim jong-nam uh went to japan
can we talk about why he was passed over
sure uh
and today is passover so he went to kim
jong-nam he went to japan his passport
which from the dominican republic uh his
chinese name in the passport translates
to fat bear because he
literally does he's the kind of
roly-poly guy um he he said he was going
to disneyland he was actually there to
collect money for like illegal arms
shipments with north korea is about and
it was kind of this joke was this sort
of his own like deal he was doing on the
side no he was officially sanctioned
there's a there's a report that just
came out uh today called illicit by
human rights for north korea i encourage
everyone to read it but just show us how
north korea has their finger in all
sorts of illicit activities because
that's their way to generate money
because they can't do kidnapping and
drugs and guns well guns and a gun
running all and counterfeiting also
other stuff and and it's this great
report um
so kim jong-nam is in japan and he got
caught
but he wanted to liberalize he went with
kim jong-il and more than one occasion
in beijing you know years apart and he
goes look what happened in beijing it's
great we should liberalize be more like
them and he goes kim jong-il says we're
not chinese
it won't work for us if you want
openness open a window
so this was a big reason and he and the
eldest son was kind of an
environmentalist which in a communist
nation is you might as well just you
know be straight out of burning man so
he was passed over right
the second son is he alive he's alive he
lives in macau yeah he wrote a book
about my father kim jong-il and in fact
when i went to north korea i had a list
of books i wanted and that was on that
list then i'm like only in retrospect
but i'm like when my guide was asking
for this book uh he must have been his
heart must have skipped a beat um the
second son is
has a hormonal imbalance is a [ __ ] and
too much like a little girl
so that was a no-go so kim jong-un was
the only one left and the idea was kim
jong-il's sister kim hyun-wi
was going to be kind of the regent
guiding him through the power succession
and she is really really she's like
joffrey she's really really evil her
daughter uh had a boyfriend or fiance
who was of a bad class and she drove her
to suicide so this is the kind of uh of
ruthlessness it's not just to the people
it's the family medieval uh power
brokering and i don't even know if
medieval was this bad i mean like we
think of medieval as being this bad but
this is a whole new kind of so they're
right they are new and unique because
the world's never seen anything like
this so kim jong-un very much promised
to stay the course just like his father
and he even looks you know he's very
much cultivating the fact that he looks
like his grandfather kimmel sung
and he's very much staying the course
like this dennis rodman kind of uh um
fetishization is a little unusual but
everything else you know he is really
not introducing any change what's your
take on this whole dennis rodman thing i
i think it's amazing that we have
concentration camps and people are
interested in this kind of you know guy
slipping on a banana uh sideshow on the
side i i
i almost can't talk about orwellian you
know i remember sending the sending you
the link to the uh video that vice had
produced about dennis rodman's visit
and you're basically like i can't watch
this yeah because you when you go there
and you see the people and you hear the
k you know the you go to the schools
right and the kids sing a song for you
and you hear they all have chess colds
because there's no heat in the school
and they don't have heat at home and
they don't have warm clothes and you
hear it all day it just it still rings
in my head
and people just want to talk about some
idiot going on a trip it's just like i
almost can't
wrap my head around the fact that there
are concentration camps where children
are being beaten to death and it's like
hey isn't this wacky this guy who
married himself remember that is friends
with this person it's like no this is
not funny to me at all and i'll tell
holocaust jokes all day long because the
holocaust is over
but this is happening right now and
uh people don't get how pervasive and
bad it is
how are we doing on time isn't he
15 minutes all right
so we used up our poignant moment we'll
have to think of something more poignant
well there's a lot of poignancy in the
book and a lot of actually there's one
of my friends had this kind of
uh
a poignant moment book which happened in
real life which is kim jong-il marry
this woman love of his life and he
couldn't make it public because she was
married before she had a kid she wasn't
a good hierarchy so his father kimball
sung is like
when are you going to get married when
are you going to give me a grandson not
knowing that he had a grandson kim
jong-nam and the grandson was being
raised in secrecy and kim jong-il is
like soon dad soon and his father found
a wife for him and forced them to get
married not realizing kim jong-il was
married before
and that moment where kim jong-il had to
sit down his first wife and be like i
had to marry somebody else
and you're still going to be a secret
and she was the like biggest movie star
in korea and the woman you know
was driven to suicidal depression and
exile to moscow to live out her life in
isolation so talk about poignancy like
the the pernicious wickedness of that
place affects everyone even the people
at the very top
towards the end of the book it it gets
very sad and um and
weirdly enough i i found myself feeling
bad for kim jong-il
um and the reason why is because he
he devotes his entire life to the
revolution
um supposedly supposedly according to
him yes yeah and uh i mean secretly he's
indulging in every luxury no he's
actually they're pretty chased like
they'd have strippers but you weren't
allowed to touch them and certainly no
one's sleeping with them yeah
did you read the article about the sushi
show yes of course which which is not
very uh reliable really yeah but that's
a whole other long story okay well
um anyway kim jong-il devotes his life
to the revolution and he can't
acknowledge his son he can't acknowledge
his lover
um
he seems
like a very lonely guy
well i mean it is i mean there's that
joke from the team america movie which
sort of kick-started this whole idea of
kim jong-il as a silly internet meme
but um you know he sings that song i'm
so lonely
and in some ways it seems like that may
have been the case yeah and that gq
article you mentioned where kim
jong-il's personal chef kind of spilled
the beans there's that moment where he
goes do you really like me
and kim jong-il asks the chef and the
chef's like of course and he goes well
if you don't i'll cut you know he makes
a motion stabbing him in the stomach but
again
i
i don't have i had to have empathy for
him to write in his voice
but to be
inferior of your dad to see people
cheering and knowing it's all a stage
production uh and to knowing these
people despised you i'm sure
uh he was not a very happy person uh i
don't think human beings are happy when
every wish of theirs is fulfilled i mean
it is not a psychologically healthy
place to be but i'm sure he's in hell
you know so i i i mean let's let's be
realistic this guy was more than happy
to let people starve just to maintain
his grip on power which is as evil as it
gets there's a very funny book there's a
moment where uh the first son who was
kept a secret
you know eventually realizes that
everything is a sham yeah and that this
everything is a charade and that kim
jong-il is just full of lies and he
finally confronts his father and says
like you're you're lying to me this is
all fake and how old's the son at the
time it's five or six yeah pretty young
yeah like what do you think is going
through kim jong-il's head well that's a
great story which is true
uh they let the sun watch south korean
tv
and kim jong-nam and when he was a kid
and he wanted to meet this host of some
children's tv show and kim jong-il is
like oh crap what are we going to do how
are we going to produce this south
korean celebrity so they find a farmer
who looks like him
they give him the costume and they have
him practiced to be an imposter
and at the sun's birthday party they
present him it's like hey look it's that
south korean celebrity like and the kid
immediately this is all true realizes
that's not the guy and he tells him he
goes this is all fake so
uh you know when you're he kim jong-il
knows his father couldn't walk across
water he knows he was born in russia and
not in in north korea he knows his
father started the korean war he knows
all these things so i i mean i i don't
think it's very you know these
sociopaths by definition are not happy
people uh he's you think that he's
hasn't drunk the kool-aid to the extent
that he's just as much of a believer as
he thinks everyone else is supposed to
be he's not drunk the kool-aid you know
because when you see him talking to
putin and you see him talking madeleine
albright when you see him talking to uh
the president of china he's very
conniving very crafty uh he this is a
great story in 2001 uh you know for
decades the north koreans have been
kidnapping japanese citizens to help
them train the north koreans to be spies
and this is regarded as nonsense another
crazy north korean story but it was all
true and when the president prime
minister of japan came to north korea
kim jong-il apologized he goes yeah we
have been kidnapping your people for
decades oops promise won't happen again
it was people under me who were you know
kind of working too hard and he thought
that this apology was going to get them
aid because it's like i came clean you
messed us up during the colonial period
give us rice and the japanese are like
are you crazy
and rather than give them rice they had
such a surplus of rice they threw it in
the ocean
because they were so apoplectic that
this was being and that you had the
nerve to apologize and think this
apology was going to be taken at face
value so
uh yeah
it's craziness but not in the sense that
you might think he knows he's not magic
in fact when he met uh this this this
famous actress that he kidnapped uh the
first thing he says to her is don't i
look like a [ __ ] turd uh look at my
physique
so he had this when he met madeleine
albright the first thing he says is here
i am the last of the communist devils so
he had can you tell the full madeline
album oh the matter alright story okay
my favorite stories that i left
unchanged were the ones that were true
because i you read them and you're like
oh this is nonsense real quick and and
telling this story
what did how did you
position it is it
in kim jong-il's words or is it a
mixture of kim jong-il's words and what
you know to be true from outside music
it's right i know it's it's he did not
put the story down it's in their
propaganda but basically the story goes
is madeleine albright goes to north
korea which really happened and she
expresses her brings the basketball she
brings the best signed by michael jordan
yes
and madeleine albright according to the
north korea this is the first i heard of
it was the north korean story she
expresses her mood via her broaches
so kim jong-il is trying to figure out
is there any reference to this outside
of north korean propaganda i'll get to
that so she's you know she shows up she
has this brooch and then she has this
one and at one point she's so enamored
with him she has a brooch of two hearts
interlocking which is a symbol which is
a pretty international symbol of love
and friendship right and i'm like oh my
god so i go back to verify this story
it's all true
she wrote a book called read my pins
about how she expresses her emotions
through her brooches and there is a
photo of her and him walking down the
hall and she has a brooch with two
hearts on it and i'm like i
that was the moment that really kind of
my head exploded uh during the book
because it was just like i i didn't know
but like you know so much of their stuff
is false and this is everything was true
yeah and it starts off with a different
kind of broach right right so she showed
up because everyone in north korea has
to have a broach on it all a pin on all
times of either the great leader the
dear leader or both of them everyone the
whole country
so she shows up with this giant american
flag like the size of a playing card to
be like screw you a we don't have to
wear brooches and my brooch is better
than yours and it's true he interprets
this as as like a big power move but it
was she said this she said i wanted to
wear this kind of flag waving
rah-rah-rah i mean i'm in my red white
and blue you know for the sake of him
like that i mean you're madeline
albright i don't know uh area 51. so
it's true so like that story of like all
the stories in the book i didn't have to
change at all i had to put in the first
person but the way they tell it actually
happens actually no there's one part
which did not happen but which was very
funny which is madeleine albright's at
this banquet and she goes how do you
count to
uh
how do you count to 16 just using your
fingers and everyone's like i don't know
and kim jong-il no one knows and he goes
like this where your thumbs make the x
so it's four times four
makes 16 and madeleine albright starts
crying and everyone applause which is a
weird sort of call back to his childhood
experience of constantly disproving his
teachers by some sort oh yeah sure that
was intentional
oh yeah it was a clever call back
yeah all this built-in irony that i
didn't know was there and then
so there's more to this madeleine
albright wears a third brooch
right of a cowboy which the north
koreans claim is the international
symbol a friend of peace
and i'm like
because cowboys promote peace no that's
my intern i'm like i have to make some
justification they don't justify
anything they're like and as she left
she had a cowboy pin which is a symbol
of peace i'm like okay it's not
and the dear readers of this book will
know it's not so i have to have some
ostensible justification and it was a
perfect segue into the george bush
chapter uh you know and obviously george
bush takes a big knock in this book and
with good reason
why
well i i think this kind of uh saber
rattling is not regarded uh very well
abroad and with good reason uh so i yeah
and the fact that george bush
unilaterally left many of these treated
treaties i have the list in the book
when you know kim jong-un criticizes him
for that like you know the u.s and the
soviet union and now russia had this
treaty since the 70s and george bush
just says you know what it doesn't apply
to us anymore that kind of
high-handedness you know is not in my
view uh very good international
relations what what was the thinking
behind that you know this grandstanding
on beh on the us's part
you're asking me why george bush did
these things i mean what do you think
i i think he was like i'm on the side of
the angels and i know what's right and
i'm not going to have a piece of paper
such as this treaty or the constitution
bind my hands
um there's some irony huh yeah
it's a very funny book parallelisms
between i i hate that okay mike huckabee
uh just last week said i think there's
more freedom in north korea than in the
u.s
that's kind of stuff enrages me because
when you realize what these people are
laboring under and you realize what life
is like
the idea that you can compare you know
the us and korea or even iran and korea
north korea is so outrageous and the
fact that they're this like i had
someone who could on my facebook compare
bloomberg to kim jong-il it's like when
you kind of you're invalidating
70 years of tragedy and you're
invalidating people who are right now a
nation of hostages thank you
i thought i'd have a good note to end up
all right
you can get dear reader on amazon or go
to kim jong-il book dot com for more
info yes we have a few copies over here
but we invite you to pick up a copy on
amazon um check out the website dear kim
jong-il book.com kim jong-il book.com
and it's 100 true
yes in quotations
so we're going to open up now for some
questions um
yes
so the tour guides have to you know each
tour guide has a different language they
speak mine spoke english but when i was
in uh the museum by the dmz there was a
tour guide there with her russian group
and she spoke russian and russians can
recognize each other in a crowd it's
kind of like black people so i go up to
this these russian people and i'm like
and they're like are you gonna apologize
to her for being a disgusting american
pig and for invading their country and
she's laughing because she knows it's a
facade and i'm like i'm so sorry we'll
never do it again she goes good make
sure you don't so i i resent enormously
when people diminish the humanity of
these people trying to make the best of
a the worst possible situation
would you say that they're brainwashed
no
that they're they're very aware of the
situation they're living i i
brainwashed this
i have kim jong-il i love that line i
have him say which is only in the
disgusting west can brainwashing be
regarded as a bad thing because they're
so filthy and dirty in the west
um
they're they're not brainwashed because
the stories don't add up and they don't
make sense you can't you can convince
people very easily that they are rich
you cannot convince them they have more
food on their plate than they did last
year and they've had to change the
propaganda and say you know we're kind
of building a better tomorrow but we're
poor so there's an increasingly
acknowledgement by the regime that uh
everything's not all it's cracked up to
be
yes
that's that's like a
death penalty felony
so you do not communicate with the world
at all but that's increasingly falling
away because you'll have cell phone
reception on the border so people from
the south will be calling through these
brokers and these little codes
and talking to their family members but
they very much pride themselves on
nothing foreign if it's not korean we
don't need to know it and if you get
caught with a cell phone if you get a
soft cell phone forget it you know but
no actually one of the great things
about the regime uh not being able to
feed the people is increasingly when you
get caught with a crime you can bribe
your way out of it so if you get caught
with that cell phone you could tell that
person who caught you i'll let you use
it for it half the time and that person
will be more than happy to look the
other way so that's a wonderful thing is
this creeping cynicism that's taking
hold over there how big is the ruling
class outside of the core family oh well
i mean the ruling cast is probably i
think like 20 30 the population is
called the the the loyal cast then you
have the wavering cast in the middle
then you have the hostile cast at the
bottom i mean the people who live
with
modern
modern amenities extremely small because
again pyongyang is the only city that
has electricity in the whole country at
night if you look at the map from space
you can see it's just this black void
north korea versus the south so even
modern amenities how many cars in the
whole country a thousand i mean that's
the level we're talking about there's
less than 100 people who are allowed to
have internet access and if you are
someone who's trusted enough to go
abroad like a diplomat or something
you're going to have family members
staying behind so if you defect those
family members are getting punished for
you defecting
yes
yes
the perspective
she said that when she first came to the
west britain people viewed the shiny
kids
almost as
other humans think they didn't mind the
code they did do their math as humans
they had the same emotions and feelings
do you think that really is the
perspective of people
yes
the question is do people really regard
the north koreans as not having emotion
there's a headline article in the daily
mail or metro one of these british
papers and the headline argument was kim
jong-un's mini-skirted robot army about
how all these women are marching in
lockstep in these parades
and when you refer to someone as a robot
you're explicitly saying this person has
no feelings dreams or emotions of their
own and they've completely been
programmed by the state and it's
absolutely false uh they giggle they
gossip they tell jokes you know they
want to look pretty they want to have a
boyfriend they want to do well in school
they love their mom so
you know any that mindset makes it seem
like the regime is effective and is
doing its job and thankfully the regime
is not as effective as it could be
all right that's all the time we have
thanks everyone thank you very much
we're going to be decamping to botanica
after this which is just up the street
uh for some drinks if you'd like and
there's like a very few books left so if
you want to grab it yeah we'll be
signing
thanks for coming thank you
all right let's hear one more time for
michael and cole
[Applause]
thanks everyone for coming out there's
two books left um i'm sure both of our
writers would be happy to sign books for
you botanica is at 47 east houston
between ma and mulberry if you'd like to
celebrate your freedom
there um but thanks again and we hope to
see you back at housing work soon
oh my god
andrew
[Music]
we'd like to hear from you tweet us your
feedback twitter.com